welcome back everybody today we're going
to talk about tractor rpms what is the
right level that you should be setting
your tractor throttle at is there a
one-size-fits-all answer i don't think
so it's more complicated than that a lot
of different scenarios let's get to it
now and as always we are proud to be
sponsored by boro wheel spacers if you
are feeling tippy on your tractor side
to side adding a set of wheel spacers
can make a big difference bora is made
in america they have a lifetime warranty
get more information at the link down
below so the overall concept of this
video is to use that throttle lever to
your advantage there are going to be
certain times you want to have it
cranked up certain times you want to
have it lowered all the way down at idle
sometimes in between the application
will determine that but one of the
common questions that is going to
typically be asked is if running their
tractor's engine at full throttle or
watt wot wide open throttle is going to
shorten the life of their diesel engine
now i am not a tractor mechanic i'm not
a diesel mechanic a lot of you guys out
there know more than i do about it so
leave your comments below with what you
can do to help other people but what i
found online is that that is typically
not going to be a concern these engines
are made to be ran at full throttle if
you need to for a long extended period
of time and in fact typically most
diesel engines run at a lower rpm even
if they are cranked all the way out
compared to a gasoline engine there's
actually quite a few folks that will say
running a diesel engine at lower rpms
for a long period of time could be worse
for it than running it at high rpms you
have more carbon buildup and that can be
an issue as well leading to more regen
cycles if you are above that 26
horsepower requirement where typically
you will have fewer regen cycles it will
be longer intervals in between if you
are running at high rpms there's more
heat that's generated more of that soot
burns off on a regular basis versus
running it at a lower rpm a lower heat
level less burn off more regen cycles
you can see where i'm going with that
now every engine manufacturer could be a
little bit different so i'd always
encourage you read through your owner's
manual see what they have to say about
it now what i will say is it's probably
more important for your startup and
shutdown procedures to be on point
you'll want to make sure you have
adequate time for that whole system to
get up to speed up to heat so to speak
so let the hydraulic fluid the motor oil
the engine block and everything heat up
that way especially on those cold winter
days there's less of a chance of a shock
to the system and something breaking or
cracking or whatever else could happen
same thing on the shutdown if you look
at a john deere manual it will recommend
that you lower that throttle down
let it rest for a couple of minutes
before turning it off so there's several
schools of thought out there but the
overarching theme is that these diesel
engines are very robust you're gonna
have to work pretty hard to damage it
but if you can follow what it says in
your manual you're gonna be okay okay so
in general adjusting that throttle
control that throttle lever is gonna
have a direct impact on some of the
other interfaces that you have with your
tractor so this will affect your ground
speed that you can actually travel with
your tractor it will affect your
hydraulic response time it will affect
the amount of hydraulic power that you
have you're going to see an impact to
your pto output speed like on a mower
deck a rototiller a brush hog that kind
of thing and like we talked about
earlier it will impact your regen
frequency on your dpf system so the
frequency that you have to go through
that regeneration process will depend
partially on the rpm level that you are
normally running now to make this a bit
more comprehensive for you as well
there's a few other considerations that
could apply here and there certain
tractors certain attachments number one
will be an epto or an economy pto so it
will still allow you to have let's say a
540 rpm rear pto spin rate even though
your engine is operating at a lower
speed this can save fuel overall perhaps
be easier on the engine and then the
tractor as well but that's something
that not every tractor is equipped with
typically the larger compacts into the
utility tractors now i hope you are
enjoying today's video if you haven't
done so yet i'd encourage you hit that
subscribe button right down below we'd
love to have you follow along get
engaged leave some comments as well and
if you are looking for something for
your tractor on the front end loader the
three-point hitch pallet fork snow
pusher grapple
box blade lamp plane rear blade
landscape break the list goes on we can
help you out check out
goodworkstractors.com a feature that
i've seen on the 2 3 and 4 series and
john deere i'm sure some other
manufacturers have that as well it's
called the auto throttle function and
what this is is it allows you to well
imagine your tractor more like a car
right and the harder you press a gas
pedal the more the engine revs up the
faster you can go it's a similar concept
with the tractor and the auto throttle
feature if you engage that button or
that knob on your tractor set your
throttle to about the mid position all
right so i'm about halfway up and so if
you push that pedal down all the way to
the ground you're gonna get that
increase in the engine rpms which can
lead to an increase in ground speed
hydraulic response time hydraulic power
you kind of get the idea and the last
thing worth mentioning it's kind of
related kind of not is the fact that
certain attachments rototillers are a
pretty good example they're oftentimes
going to have additional gears in their
gear box where you can switch things out
or rotate them around to get different
ground speeds for the uh the rate that
the tines spin to make it work with your
tractor so who knows maybe there's a way
if you wanted to really go all out and
try to really fine tune your tractor and
your attachment setup you could tweak
things here and there maybe run it to
lower rpm adjust the gear setting here
and there i don't know that's beyond my
skill set but i thought it was worth
mentioning all right so i had to take a
whole lot of notes here to keep things
straight up in the old noggin so first
we want to talk about when you should
run your rpms at a high level or full
throttle
wide open throttle wot and so the first
example is anytime that you are going to
be using a pto attachment and this could
be for the mid pto the rear pto even a
front mounted pto which technically or
typically runs off of the mid pto so
snow blowers mower decks tillers brush
hogs those kinds of attachments that use
a gearbox to drive the blades the auger
whatever's being run off of the pto and
you need to use this at wide open
throttle or very close to it sometimes
you will see a little pto symbol right
on your rpm gauge move that throttle up
until the needle hits that pto symbol
and that means it's going to get you the
required 540 rpms at the rear pto maybe
it's 2 000 rpms coming off the mid pto
whatever it is that's what the
attachment is designed to operate at so
if you lower your engine rpms down
you're going to have a lower speed on
the output for the attachment as well
which means it's not going to perform as
intended and you're not going to get the
desired results and so oftentimes i will
use that little symbol as a guideline
right so maybe if you're using your
belly mower it's not that big of a deal
you can kind of bury that needle right
on there you're going to be okay but if
i'm using a tiller and i'm going along
you know like out on our property it's
going to start to bog down at some point
you're going to see
typically on a digital gauge where it's
going to tell you you're down to 500
rpms or 510 rpms or 520 whatever it is
and number one you should use that as a
queue to slow down you're going too fast
but number two that's why i like to
sometimes push it that throttle just a
little bit above what it's supposed to
be at because it's going to compensate
once that implement is engaged and
having some resistance placed on it now
a few other times when you want to
typically run at wide open throttle will
be of course if you are kind of in
transport mode just moving from point a
to point b you want to be in your
highest range so you can move as fast as
you possibly can and full throttle will
let you get there as fast as possible
the only downside is that typically in
the high range and at full throttle if
you are going up a hill you're not going
to have very much low end torque and so
i have been guilty of stalling out my
tractor on really big hills because you
just don't have the oomph that you need
to get up there so that mode is really
good on a flat no load type of situation
where you just want to get where you got
to go as fast as possible another common
application when you have that throttle
all the way up is when you need as much
power as possible and not just on the
rear pto or the mid pto but on your
front end loader if you have a really
heavy load that you have to get lifted
up you're going to get the most
hydraulic power out of your system with
that engine cranked all the way up
because the engine is what drives
everything else on your tractor
including the hydraulic pumps so the
faster everything is operating the more
flow that you have and the more power
alright so now there are some very
specific applications when it pays to
have that throttle crank down low maybe
not to idle but we're going to say
anything less than that wide open
throttle there could be different
settings always play around with those
settings just see what works for you
oftentimes if i'm doing loader work
let's say i have a big pile of dirt or
mulch or something else i could find
myself constantly playing with the
hydraulic control maybe as i move from
point a to point b i'm at full throttle
but then when i get to a load i may
cranking down a little bit to have more
fine tune control over my loader
joystick and so that's really one of the
most common applications is when you're
going to be using your hydraulic system
typically on the front end loader it
could be on the backhoe as well but
sometimes these tractors come with a
very quick hydraulic system all right
the john deere 3e series for example is
lightning fast on its response time with
the loader controls it's almost too fast
which seems counterintuitive but
i oftentimes will lower that throttle
control down just to give myself some
more control over what i can do with a
bucket if i want to kind of just
gradually spill some material out if i
want to make sure i'm getting very level
as i'm driving into a pile now the same
thing can be said on a backhoe is that
if you want to move left to right as
you're dumping and scooping piles moving
back and forth you can feel real jerky
on there it feels unnatural and annoying
so the flip side of course is if you are
lowering your engine throttle you're not
going to have as much digging power with
your backhoe now for a lot of
applications you don't necessarily need
to max out your backhoe or your loader
and get every last ounce of power out of
it it's more about being able to use
that power efficiently and effectively
and not make a big old mess a couple
other applications when you may want to
run a little bit less than full throttle
of course when you're warming it up and
cooling it down
pull that throttle lever down maybe
halfway maybe just a little bit above
idle if you want to
check your manual see what it has to say
we learned a new application this summer
ourselves when our 4720 was overheating
in the hot summer sun we ended up
actually turning our tractor off as it
was overheating and when we posted that
video we had a lot of really good
comments there that said hey don't turn
your tractor off keep it on lower that
throttle down so it's not generating a
ton of heat but if you lower that
throttle down the cooling system will
keep working and help that extra heat
dissipate going to lower your overall
engine temperature and help your tractor
recover quicker and of course these
tractors are very efficient so if you
find yourself getting your jobs done too
quickly just slow it down all right just
slow it down lower that engine throttle
take a little longer watch that sunset
enjoy your tractor time now there of
course are going to be a lot of times
when the engine rpms don't really matter
a whole lot and what i have found using
tractors myself is that typically in
applications like grading out your
driveway with a landscape rake with a
land plane something that's not putting
a heavy load on the tractor you can just
kind of set it in cruise go a mid rpm
level do what you want just to get the
speed you want to go there's not going
to be a lot of strain in the machine or
on the engine so it's easy to get your
job done same thing can be said if
you're just pulling along a wagon or a
trailer typically not a whole lot of
strain being placed on the tractor if
you're on flat ground you know now it
can also depend what kind of ground
you're on if you're in the mud if you're
in snow and ice and you have the engine
cranked up too high it could mean that
your tires are just sitting there
slipping and sliding around and maybe
lowering that engine rpm a little bit
could lead to your advantage of course
that could also tie into the type of
tire that you have on your tractor which
is a whole other story that we've talked
about before but hopefully this points
you in the right direction gives you
some insight as you're sitting on your
tractor getting to use it getting to
know what it's all about use that lever
that throttle lever you can work it to
your advantage and make a big difference
on how you interact with your tractor so
i do hope you enjoyed today's video and
again if you haven't subscribed yet i'd
encourage you hit that subscribe button
right down below we'd love to have you
join the party and if you are looking
for a tractor attachment for the front
end loader for the three-point hitch we
sell and ship all over the country we'd
love to earn your business check out
goodworkstractors.com i want to thank
you for taking time out of your day to
stop by and until next time stay safe
we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
bye